[Music]
canary personals so information security
it's really important right so the ad
you're developing your product your
information security must be engaged
this luckily before for your DevOps
right
DevOps don't do that it does not begin
when the product is being developed and
they're done and handed over them has to
begin at the very beginning of
development because as a part of the
development you have to implement um you
have to include your information
security team with the part of that
development or it's going to cause more
problems down the road guarantee it
okay now the other key point is that
security does come at a cost and as
always this balance between each of us
response time and security now if my
monthly if your system was the most
lockdown system in the world chances are
it could be the best system in the world
right you can have the most secure
system in the world and what you decided
to do to make it the most experiences
for the world and I didn't connecting to
the internet well let's see how long
people are going to keep purchasing that
tool so the answer cannot be I want to
remove to the Internet the answer has to
be I have to balance my security
concerns with my operational needs to
kind of create the most effective tool
to actually be a balance
all right what however they are a number
a principle that you can apply to reduce
the risk okay now I'm going to give you
another access to a tool that I think is
really key in this area and it's the
only tool that I'm aware of that does
something like this so
and it's called a c-corp vault
opportunity and the nest box were you
always trying to go to the ceiling open
source school and while we can't get
into all the specifics of it but I've
used it and it's pretty powerful and I'm
only beginning to scratch the surface of
it but what it does is that it allows
you to take it well it's literally right
here
it's Sakura stores and tightly tightly
controls access to information or
secrets that you need so this becomes
very powerful because it allows it
manages users as well as machine access
to different information
and additionally it allows you access it
does all your certification
certification management it does network
of cooking as a service it does a
credential management for AWS in a few
elements various databases and
expeditious a lot more I mean it's a
really powerful tool I've set it up it
is really eat or user friendly but
hopefully in what it does that it allows
me to kind of protect information and
it's a real powerful tool that kind of
like to do that if there's something
that someone's interested in I would
recommend it's kinda it again it's open
source um but they do have an enterprise
version as well I you pay for like
really expand for in this case is mostly
their their expertise not as much as the
product itself ok so anyway but this is
a great tool to kind of helps you
implement the things that we're talking
about this is one of them anyway and get
these other ways doing it again I'm all
about just kind of introduce me the
tools and you kind of figure out what
works best for you and your organization
under principles so one key principle is
there's notion of defense in depth ok so
you see this diagram on the right hand
side but ultimately what it is is that
it is the the practice of arranging
defensive layers so that you can
uh the spend each layer where each layer
is independent of the previous layer so
in this case doing that it is that you
know person at the very top that's
trying to get to your internal
application server so in this case I set
a strategy of deepest in depth trying to
isolate that even if this person gets
through the firewall it doesn't mean
they have access to everything else they
still got to work their way through uh
my DMV I mean where my web server is
that my web server has been hardened it
has all the stats virus scanners on
there and so forth all of the powerful
missions the action control is a set of
evidence so that gets to each individual
layer in order for me to get to the
application server excuse me out here so
so when you set it up where do the come
to get to one thing they don't get to
the other that is a defense-in-depth way
of engineering your security system and
this is one of the more common ways that
they're engineered so if you do a
firewall of the mean you have X step
thing else for you to give me to me you
have access to the internal firewall
right so everything is layer to ensure
that once you get extra one thing you
don't get X to the kitten caboodle um so
so the largest area please elaborate on
the DMZ so I mean did you know in DMV if
they ever say demilitarized zone right
if normally it's like a buffer area good
from a military standpoint it's like a
buffer between your place where you live
and be innocent so you have this like
matter-of-fact so they'll even crunches
em like you know I know in these things
I think you hear a lot about Korea right
so between North Korea and South Korea
there's this DMZ this denotes horizon
that nobody can kind of go into what it
does it gives you a buffer between you
and them principally this DMV is the
same thing that you see here and get
different death it's like the buffer
between the outside and the inside all
right
but it all got it in action
so in this buffer in this case this is
where you're going to kind of put some
more checks in to make sure nobody's
getting through this knife post get
through in this case you have access
control lists you have a hope you have a
hope kids what is called but especially
all that is like virus scanners or
things of that nature and then you have
a hardened bill they kind of shuts down
ports it down unwanted a network access
all kind of things right so this is your
DMV all right any other questions
all right move it on so who died was
beaten to death
okay so interesting up 80% website
vulnerabilities come from this thing
called cross-site scripting
cross-site scripting all right so what
is that so often you may hear these
things called attack vectors all right
but attack that there is just that it's
just a way that people can use to get in
that is a and attack vector the more you
reduce attack vectors the more secure
your system is okay
so this attack vector called cross-site
scripting it accounts for over 80% of
website vulnerabilities and really all
all it is is like this in the connect
second bullet an email a website
contains a link to another website right
so it could be like they put this
harmless link he's making you may see it
right um like you go to your page and
and and you click on a link or are you
some webpage and then they have all
these these pop-ups and usually people
to Yahoo for you Beck let's let's go
there
cuz yahoo notorious for having them
right so you go down here
and some of these are valid links to the
webpage but every once a while like Oh
private a fydd y you can be pictures
over here on the side over there they'll
have any different amortize ones that
come up and one of them might say hey
find out what this person did
all right like this one here
maybe they're just babies get out of
cash now right and I'm gonna click on it
because I'm always kind of leery about
like this but what it is potentially
that could be a cross scripting link it
looks like one thing on this page but if
you go to it it kind of kicks off some
JavaScript that performs some function
that allows your system to become
compromised right
that is what cross fifteen years
it looks like one thing on your webpage
but when you click it it does something
else and then it kind of provides other
because of other issue on your system
cross-cutting
all right so so in this case cuz you
want to link calls we call it the
browser to execute some code in the
email case and then it allows them to
kind of email justice information and
make it be a variety of thing right
another case would be that a web server
stores where all user data and then
because of the way they engineered it it
is because they fail to implement proper
escaping of stating mechanisms and
escaping is kind of like this characters
there are some key characters that every
language has and like for example in C
if you were to do something like this in
Ambassador to the in text box those
quotation marks mean to means that it's
a string
so really what it's saying is that the
screen begins with letter J
right but if you wanted this quotation
mark to be a part of the string I was
going to do something like this
you
I would need to put these where they
call escape characters in front of a dog
sorry I just put it on the text box I
would need to put these escape
characters in front of the quotation
marks so that's included as a part of
the entire stream so sometimes when you
fail to properly escape things you cause
your system more filters you enable
people to do things your system by
simply in this case by not properly
escaping the things that you said right
okay so let me go back to big screen now
other things you do again somebody picks
and depth now you should also try to
minimize your attack services right so
you have to minimize the number of
points into your system that's your goal
and that's what you should be about it
whatever way you can do that is no you
should do it this is so one of the most
common ways of minimizing attack
services is updating your browser
updating your OS people are figuring out
things all the time
right and the more you can update things
to overcome attack services the better
because what longtime updates are based
upon overcoming security issues right so
one of the more common way to minimize
impacts covers is updating your software
and that includes updating any
applications you're building the same
thing happens you build it based upon
some principle so you want to make sure
you're not allowing these
vulnerabilities get into your system
now there's another concept called feel
secure right
so generally these that we say you want
to feel secure versus feeling safe
you when building the application as a
general rule you want to feel secure
versus feeling safe so what is a what
feeling thing so if in this page you
have a door and if the power sets off
right you know instead of everything
shutting down the door is going to open
that feeling safe or gonna get it emit
from from a software standpoint if we
have a function that checks for null for
example check for nulls say see them an
empty
you'll fail say if if you know if it is
fails of the delicate embrace it still
continues
that could be a felon safe or private
said if it fells if it's a null you can
said you put another value in there that
could be filled safe whereas telling
secure is if it with the power of
Ecuador mechanism if the power fails the
door locks all activity ceases so the
question is system should so with the
point in its system should they'll
secure versus failing safe so let's look
at this this this question what happens
when the stores connected to credit card
validation of system fails so if you
would you go to close towards getting
person your credit card they swipe it
and then the stores connection whether
it's the store or whether it's the
actual server on the other end the
connection fails what should happen well
here's a
so I think everybody was here for a
moment they're trying to figure out how
to download this
I think if you go to file black and so
we're on this run I went back to our
links where everyone kind of take a look
at it so you go to file and you can
download ass whatever in little lies
down
okay that's how you get some I asked a
question earlier everyone make sure I
kind of cover that either way like if
this is a great link while we can't
spend a lot of time talking about in
great depth can get a lot of face to
cover I did want to point out that there
is a
a II was dead right here
in this wink and now put that link here
you
you
you
put it in this box but this this is a
great page that that covers this concept
and great depth I wouldn't recommend
that you kind of take a look at it
because again it does a bang-up job of
explaining very specifically why we're
talking about is important but it is
short to answer this question what
happens when the sports make it to a
credit bar validation system fails
ultimately what the what the store has
was what the credit card has to ask us
to deal with is if the connection fails
if that's the air
then if they allow people to come in and
approve many things or if the source
connection bill that could be one
problem that if if there's one fan is
that the error has to be very kind of
clearer to just a large degree and they
should in this case they share the fail
secure in other words shut the door
nothing else works because if not it
opens up possibilities for a lot of
fraud and it opens up possibilities for
performance for now when you subscribe
but for liability as I'm trying to say
liability and it was a lot of liability
on the store versus the people providing
the service because so my point is in
order to prevent that they do instead
that if it fails
these are locking everything down
altogether I work building secure okay
all right
other key concepts um least privileged
grunting any questions any questions
you
all right what could be man all right
least privileged all right so a general
rule you only want to give people the
the minimum privilege they need in order
to do their job you want to the max
because I found even in my own personal
experience but honestly I find that
really I only need access to a handful
of thing from day to day very rarely do
I need access to all things right and so
um so my vibe reading least privilege or
the minimum privilege needed to do their
job it's going to improve security
stability and your requires not let's
unleash them out of testing and it makes
deploying everything easier because I
can just do the minimum and what I also
talked about just sorting through it out
there again is the notion of minimum
viable solution or minimal Viable
Product what is the little thing I can
do to still meet the requirements and
that's what I want to do and here's a
good example of this a backup system all
in these reactions to the data is
backing up it doesn't need to be able to
write to the same directory where it's
that it's backing up you're going to
need that so don't do it don't give it
to them leave scrimmage access and then
another thing another point to think
about its security through obscurity
right right you should be hiding
something doesn't make it more secure
that I think we all kind of understand
that like for example often once they
think this developers had you not been
guilty of myself quite honestly is I'll
create a link and make a way for anybody
that has this link to access this this
data well if I'm going to do that it's
good it's fine not a problem but it
I'm doing it and I'm saying it's secure
I'm incorrect and I'm wrong right there
because it's hitting but most people
doesn't mean that it's more secure
listen it okay you know so what are some
kind of way they do that right they take
a server a web server and put it on
another port well it doesn't mean that
it's more secure it's just not in the
same place that it was before
right um generally you know another
another important point they say well
just because I use cryptography means
that I I'm securing my information more
well it used to be a time we're gonna
employees used to be only cryptographers
well guess what that's not always true
anymore
right there are a lot of cryptographic
algorithms that are published now and so
if you give you the right one
particularly a lot of you may have
access to it I think you want to recall
that article that Google just publish
about some cryptography something that
they've broken the demo recall that
yeah no one's talking about it all
nope well okay yeah so there was a
Google put out a link or the paper they
described how do you go about breaking
some level of cognitive and it took them
like some number of weeks to do with all
their computers so my only point being
is you know this because you encrypt it
doesn't Michigan doesn't necessarily
mean that it's also secure or right so
hiding it and things of that nature
isn't the way to say that my system is
secure right the way to do that is by
having a good effect ocation good
authorizations good a lot of things
that's how you don't ever been a solid
insecure system
all right initially right using modern
languages I can't stress this enough
like I love you know I'm live with it I
would say I love feed but that's not
time true I you see and I enjoy using it
because it allows me to do more about
what I want to do but the absolute truth
is that see when you use that language
it opens you up to more security
problems well why because it allows you
to perform more lower level functions
well door that isn't necessarily a bad
idea but the problem is that a lot of
these languages like Java Kotlin the few
other ones they have a lot of the
security things already considered as a
part of their core language so when you
say performance go get to man they like
the consideration that if it's a null or
null make sure the air out there's a
buffer overflow make sure you air out
you see this make sure you do this in
that right so using an up-to-date
language is really steep
so we're testing Balaji because it's 40
points a memory Krantz issues absolutely
with a receipt yes Balaji talks about
Java heap size issues as well yes
excellent point Balaji absolutely these
are all things that you know that are
part of the reasons why silly things are
used but it also points out some of the
reasons why certain place to have it
like having a proper job Java heat sighs
you know that that's important in that
it it allows you to it doesn't wait the
application when your Java heat size
which is kind of a place where Java
instructions run in your Java heap so it
has to be a certain size to allow for a
certain level of performance and for
Java code there runs the test part of
that memory management is allowed and
see yeah exactly and then in it that's
one of the lower-level functions that I
was talking about right so these little
languages making they can be good it but
they allow access to doing things that
could really be harmful to your system
so if you're using these systems check
are these languages well chips are you
aware that however we always have to
kind of be aware of some of the things
that kind of go along with it right so
you know to the best ability you want to
use modern languages
additionally you want to make sure you
keep it simple right just because of the
complex doesn't mean that it's the best
and it's been proven that simple
solutions they get they hack your
security risk why because the security
portions of that are often more well
understood and then just simply having a
complicated solution often just even
understanding the wide something failed
is problematic
I mean I have a system to have probably
about thirty thousand lines of code and
I hate that system because any time
something breaks I have to go through
like this big process to figure out why
it broke and I hate it because the code
is so complicated and it's outdated on
top of that
so we use a lot of like weird job a18
now primarily elderly there's a double
1:9 but which is you like Java 1.5 ways
of doing things and sometimes doing that
is this is a lot of space and it's very
complicated so anyway so overcomplicate
exclusive often have secured obscure fea
pass
so we can front up so gold-plating can
be the issue gold flavor can be an issue
only from the sense of extending because
remember gold plating is the notion of
taking a requirement and adding all
these unofficial things
that doesn't bring value that's what
gold packets so gold plating can be a
security issue if it's not well thought
out and or
and or if it was kind of just thrown in
there if you would so often candidates
for issues are things that with the
initial requirements and some of them
just kind of added on their own those
are prime candidates for where things go
wrong
all right any other questions
all right so um seeing it I'll have to
very quickly get accomplished piece the
figuration file and I've seen this
before
anyway 82 the mail servers in 1996
your aunt went over to the mill 7 in
2013 in favor of easier to configure
alternative yes so like having because
you have a figuration file that say I
bet if I just show you
well not activate so
similar all that it is that it was yes
Isabel application that's all yes yes
like outlet right all right but let's
pacifically you know you need to take
outlet put it on multiple servers
but in order to configure SCIM mail it
was it was largely depended upon
figuration files
right how much where I'd like to go was
like you Lisa used to have a similar you
can access it online as well so
all right now segregation duties right
so we if you don't do this I guarantee
this will cause you problems as an
organization and the general approach
you don't want all your eggs in one
basket
you want to make sure that there are
clear lines of suggestion of duties and
you have critical functions that
requires multiple people or multiple
entities to work together to accomplish
it so for example probably one common
way of doing this if you got a date
warehouse what you don't want is one
person to have access to all of the your
databases so what you might say in order
for anybody to access your data
warehouse there always have to be two
person integrity two people are required
to go in and work together to accomplish
some goal
all right that could be a segregation of
duties
so there's notion of dividing critical
functions in two steps and no processes
or piece number of people to accomplish
a specific goal
all right now another thing trust in the
fleet mediation trust
so
all right so trust mediation is when two
parties you change credentials and then
we required no further checks that's
trust complete mediation right so um
we're complete mediation is where
dentals are checked on every access
all right so often systems they're gonna
generate some kind of tide based token
like for example with with Gmail well if
I little bit probably a better example
is uh for most the time when you're
operating Windows initially but if
you're not moving your mouse around for
some amount of time it's going to reduce
it's going to log you out right
that's a same principle it's the same no
support token this token is this goal is
going to this total is going to be
authenticated and authorized for an X
amount of time and then they have to be
read Arif I discussed at some point
right and so often those are ways to do
that like with I showed you that vault
vault hexa core vault it does that for
you that's one of the things that I do
that it does it has the ability to
require that when they because their
token if we're going to once they make
they have X amount of time to access and
do their jobs then after that makes a
reader hiding right so that's one thing
to the dusk last one is single sign-on
isn't it sort of compromise right so one
way that they kind of do this is that a
better acceptable way of working through
this is single sign-on and this single
sign-on kind of allows you to it kind of
avoids the need for multiple passwords
so like for Google for example you have
a single sign-on and this single sign-on
they have this family of tools that you
now have access to access to right but
which is with that they also give you
the ability to have a to pass site on
our to factor authentication right and
so one way to do that is you only get up
leaving your username and password but
it sends your even your
to your email say I'm kind of log on but
yes to allow you to allow you to log on
and there so that way they kind of tooth
actor that's two factor authentication
okay but single sign-on is a common way
of compromise to keep kind of work
through this pressing the clean
mediation okay all right but that being
said we're going to hit our first break
are there any questions any questions
alright so before you go on your break
we're going we're going to implement a
the polls will open up the poll poll for
you please please call the part of the
class and will avoid came in a break if
I can evacuate she's ready to go at add
time five minutes 15 minutes for now
we're going to start Kenan okay all
right it's going to go on for two minute
break if you could also put a little
coffee uh icon now I know you're on
break and you have any questions again
slipping up alright so get on break so
yeah 15 minutes from now
Wow we're on break I'm going to ask a
few questions
Jerome ass I'm hearing a new Quinn
suppose like secure devops is there
additional security manifestos add it
with what we are discussing now um
that's a good question um generally I've
heard of secure DevOps but I haven't see
anything formal uh that separates the
two and any great length I do think that
[Music]
uh the implication is that secure DevOps
they're focusing on the security
portions of the DevOps but I don't
necessarily think that it's it's any
different per se it's just that your
focus is different like they're they're
off the hook song release management you
notice they call them release management
DevOps
that's just a part of the extended part
of DevOps we're in secured to have our I
think they're focusing more on that
security element
all right don't reinvent the wheel get
which piece is talking about security
all right and so the whole point of this
slide is to kind of talk about you know
don't try to necessarily come up with
your own security solution per se right
while solutions should be tailored to
meet your specific need but you don't
have to reinvent the wheel in order to
ensure your security concern is met and
your security risks are mitigated
properly so use existing and known and
reliable security software Suites right
don't you have to recreate your own to
make this work all right um the UNIX the
tcp/ip stack has been around a long time
it stayed stable and reliable right you
don't have to try to come up your own
protocols in order to communicate I use
what's there and what's available
because we understand all the security
implications around it this Lee that's
similar to saying like you know you you
have a need to communicate via messaging
to to to but in order to ensure that
your team can collaborate well there
really isn't much value if you're going
to create your own messaging system when
there's like so many other options that
are available why do that why waste the
money to develop it when you can quite
operating with open source things that
are free or at very little cost and
accomplish the what you want done in a
in a better fashion and in a more secure
fashion all right so you know take
advantage of what's been done already a
lot of lot of times other operating
system vendors implements our own stack
right and and these had model build
which have been discovered and fixed in
UNIX right so the point being make sure
that you the most possible leverage
what's already been done
we're just creating something new now
passwords passwords as you know our
problematic for a lot of organizations
but really them so Balaji's can you
mention the fact that as a part of what
we're talking about nor if it will
network related concepts are also part
of the DevOps
model which includes switches routers
and they actually are but you know
you're right it is part of that so there
are some some there are some templates
of things that have been done already
and those things that have been done
already they work for certain use cases
so what we don't want you to do is go
create your new firewall because that's
what you want to do right take advantage
of the the firewalls that are already in
place and use those and unless there's a
reason not to use it then you know then
you definitely want to talk about those
reasons but you know but again these
things before people with thousands of I
think you know look at something and
taking a look at it to see if they
aren't cheap to fix to verify in their
insecurity risk you know those are good
tools use and then get starting points
so um just your passwords right so many
people have security reason area secure
passwords and they do things like those
are names in there they kind of their
address all kinds of things well why you
can do that in and unique kind of ways
in order to make it secure but but for
the most part you definitely want to put
it in policies that allow for securing
strong
passwords and not you know they check
for certain things like you know birth
dates that checks for people's names and
things of that nature as much as
possible in order to ensure a secure
system now in in databases oftentimes
passwords are not stored or they
shouldn't be stored in plain language in
the database they should be stored
generally as a one-way hash meaning that
you can go from once you put it in it
takes it and if you would look applies
it your password times an integer as a
cheap example and it's really kind of
simple but the point being is that that
multiplication will only work one way
all right so if I wanted to go the other
way I do some something else to make
that work in this case about I would
need to divide it by something right so
so um but so you know generally a good
rule of thumb we storm a short passage
database it should be stored as some
type of one-way hash you know there
converts going in one way you I couldn't
take that same waiting to bring it on
the way out I would have to perform a
different function in order to figure
that out okay all right um securing
passwords so salt earlier we talked
about we threw out a few tools out there
some of them included ant ansible we
talked about puppet and they will talk
about chef just just feel a little um
love to talk about but specifically in
our case we're looking at salt those
forces that I talked about ansible
puppet chef salt they're all kind of
these management tools these system
management tools
configuration management IT management
Isis but they're officially called so
salt is a tool that can be used to help
obscure passwords and way that it does
it it takes random
fits size numbers so if you would it'll
it'll take ten an integer that has ten
characters or ten digits and it will
take those ten digits and it will
randomize those and add it to your
password and store that with and in
store in that store with the resulting
hash so in the way they do that is by
doing that it reduces the chance that
mythical passwords will generate the
same hash right so even they have the
same password like before if I just can
kind of converted a hash by some factor
arm password by some factor I can it had
the same hash it would be safe to say
that those two users have the same
password what this does is that when the
net password is generated it add some
number to
it has some number T of the password and
then by doing that it ensures that the
past the passwords won't for the hash to
support those different users won't
match so that's what that's about
so if there are ways of making secure
but middle passwords like often just
kind of give you a thing that I that I
that I do on a 40 keyboard for example I
may take a pattern and say this is gonna
be my pattern for this you know for you
know this year and then my pattern I
just kind of move from places on the
keyboard and then I start my 30-point
keyboard to look different but it's a
pattern and so and I use combinations of
ships and controlled and all kind of
things with unless the point being it
makes it very it makes it very memorable
to to remember how what my password is
for a particular system
another way is take two short unrelated
words and put numbers and symbols in
front of them right and these word the
symbols could mean something to you like
like for example with just if you know
my number for the year maybe 42 for me
in the United States there was a
baseball player named Jackie Robinson
Jackie Robinson wore the number 42 and
so I may say you know my number for the
next five months may be his number and
then I put a combination of things
together to ten and meet the complexity
I need in order to make sure my long
passwords are both secure all right so
uh secure ID security is a tool
so retention answer question what move
on I've memorized such complex passwords
well the way that I've analyzed complex
passwords is really either by patterns
or by keep like for the common humanity
Dometic newer devices the word would
come to me in a second what I do is I'll
take a you know these these concepts of
cutaway things connect right I'm wait
one thing you can do you might say my
sister is I have a sister and she's 36
so I may say you know in 36 and then
what I might use is that this time I
might might use 1936 2036
21:36 that may be my entire password and
but always I remember it was 36 was
because of my sister right so you got to
find a way to kind of take a hold of
those complexities
and using memory devices to remember
what they are right here ID alright so
this is a common way that people use
picking businesses I see it a lot of
businesses where they'll have something
like this
and they have this little key fob and
they provide it generates a random
number at film periodicity so this is
called secure ID and it's often used for
remote authentication so it usually is
the issue with the device that adds this
this number that's generated at some
periodicity and then what happened is
that the user is going to authenticate
with their pin and we're going to
authenticate with this secure ID so
there's a there's something there's a
there's apps for this kind of stuff now
like you see but finally
like we're to go to Google oops you
google car play
and
[Music]
yeah so this is just duo mobile app and
this destroy everyone can have it I'll
put this in your in the chat box
this is one that kind of sets up a st.
principally the same kind of thing the
two factor authentication I'll talk
about earlier and essentially what it
does is that it's going to generate like
this random number as you feel of to the
right of the screen over here it's going
to generate this random number just like
right over here is going to generate
that random number and then you're going
to use that as part of your
authentication
so that's one way that it went perfectly
the same thing as this your ID the
server the server that this app runs off
it is going to have a clock in a
database of seeds for each of supported
secure ID so for each one of these
security that someone has they're going
to it's going to just going to have a
database entry for it now with this uh
the clocks can get out of state but you
can go to the to the server and adjust
it to make sure that everything is in
sync with the device and with the server
so that when you put in your PIN plus
this this number the secure ID it'll
have that on there
all right some other ways of indicating
is through biometrics right so you can
have some of these authenticating
factors fingerprinting retinal scan
space recognition voice prints typing
patterns etc now while some of these
things are have to do a lot of these
things you know quite honestly but
unless these these tools they're object
well they're not feeling as expensive as
they used to be but you know if you were
able to fish at an organizational level
it's still they present a some financial
difficulty in implementing this across
the entire organization often what they
do is for the more secure areas that
they need to hold people accountable
they'll create more biometric points of
entry that that authenticates you by
looking at these some tea biometric
figures so many orders will have
information security teams right and
they all kind of play a role in reducing
the risk associated with security and
ensuring compliance throughout the
organization but I want to say this and
I think it's important to work them it's
worth repeating that mission it's very
important that the infamous security
teams are engaged as a part of
production are part of developing your
tool set in the early you engage with
them the better off your team is I
really can't stress that enough
right and so engage them as a part of
this process don't treat them as if they
have the bubonic plague which is I could
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here